die app clubhouse sorgt seit dem
wochenende für große aufregung auf
social media die sprache konferenz aus
den usa gibt es bereits seit märz 2020
bislang kann man aber nur als apple user
und mit einer exklusiven einladung
beitreten umweltaktivistin luisa
neubauer nutzt die plattform bereit und
bietet klima talks an
jetzt aber kurz hier bei clubhouse seit
um 19 uhr gibt es das klima dort mein
kleines feature kommt dazu schöpft
fußballer mats hummels oder konkreteren
kamutzki sind der app schon beigetreten
bloggerin xenia dawns ist noch kein cent
ihr freund hat ihren account trotzdem
erstellt um den live podcast zu lauschen
macht es mit clubhaus auf sich hat wie
wertvoll die app ist und ob sie in
zukunft zu unseren täglichen apps dazu
gehört haben uns manager kevin tiere und
ins leiterin diana zu lügen exklusiv
erzählt ja das ist auf jeden fall
bringen
[Musik]
ich benutze den abendstunden natürlich
nicht jene der arbeit oder auch irgendwo
hört sich von der familie bin aber
abends und dabei alle plätze und es war
sehr viel spaß und ich glaube es trifft
gerade jetzt sind derzeit ob es nach der
tanten ihre will alles wie ein bisschen
formal noch am status wage ich zu
bezweifeln aber genau die jetzt fällt
ist halt genau die neat betreffen uns
nicht mehr in die komplette auf ideen in
lockerem zusammenkommen
und dafür ist einfach perfekt
die leute die sonst dafür aber schon
getroffen oder bei weltcup unbezwungen
und dann wenn man anruft dann hat mein
grund oder im zoom kommen muss man mal
offiziell was macht hat und man redet
sich einfach einen smalltalk und
deswegen ist clubhaus einfach perfekt
also mich hat die app passt schon in
ihren bann gezogen was ich auch ein
bisschen bedenklich sind weil es eben
noch eine weitere plattform ist die man
als kelter auch bedienen kann vielleicht
auch sollte und die eben wirklich total
inspirierend sein kann also ich hatte
jetzt schon über das wochenende ganz
viele spannende gespräche mit leuten mit
denen ich recht so jetzt einfach nicht
mal in kontakt gekommen wäre und das
finde ich wirklich eine ganz tolle
möglichkeit man hat eben die option über
wie system zu sprechen aber man kann
auch über alles andere reden was
natürlich sehr stark diskutiert wird
gaga ist auch dass die plattform nicht
zu gehörlos geeignet ist und dass
natürlich eben nicht jeder so leicht
rein kommt und das stößt vielen negativ
auf aber ich glaube das ist eher so eine
frage der zeit dass bei geben immer mehr
menschen auch tun bekommen und auch
plattform wie instagram schließen ja
auch nicht jeden ein also entwicklung
ist ja zb auch er sehr schwierig wenn
man eben nicht sehen kann und ich glaube
das wird sich alles noch in den nächsten
monaten vielleicht ein bisschen
[Musik]